right now we're only doing nine cities
right but on the you know we had these
press before the whole thing shifted
gear but we were going to do 24 cities
or something like that
i had a whole band um
and basically what happened is uh
when we started figuring out what was
going on with the mandates what was also
happening with like if anybody gets sick
what you have to deal with right we were
like yo we can't take this risk because
financially you could just sink yourself
so they had a full band
um and if one person gets sick
you can't put them on the bus you can't
fly them home you have to leave them in
that city
for 10 days pay for their hotels
pay them pay them their per diem fly
someone new in the same day have them
learn all the parts and then pay them so
now you're paying double triple and
that's only if one person gets sick so
imagine if three people get right and
then you know that's gonna happen right
somebody get exposed
so we was like yo we can't be out here
paying for
30 hotel you know nights and and doing
so it just didn't make sense so we just
shrunk the show down
we uh limited our exposure down to like
17 days on the road instead of 40. right
so if anyone gets sick by the time you
know we find out hopefully they can be
home to quarantine but everyone's good
so far damn it's weird man it's a weird
time even the tour too